the three capital police officers that
were who immediately returned fire when
the gunmen attacked a Republican
baseball practice
are being called heroes special agents
crystal Greiner David Bailey and Henry
Cabrera
were on the scene when the gunman opened
fire Greiner and Bailey rushed him
despite their own wounds chip Reid is
outside the Capitol with new details on
their bravery chip good morning well
good morning as a remember of the
Republican leadership Congressman Steve
Scalise travels with a protective detail
of Capitol Police Officers so it's a
very good thing he was there yesterday
because his security team kept that
baseball field from becoming a killing
field I know as sure as I'm standing
here right now that there's no way we
would have lived through that
representative Mike Bishop told our
Scott Pelley two of the agents rushed
onto the field as the congressman and
staffers fled problem is that he's got a
rifle and they've got handguns and it's
not a fair fight at that point in time
they knew they work and it probably hit
him they were just trying to give us
cover a third agent shot at the gunman
from behind the first base dugout where
Senator Jeff Flake sought safety yelled
out is it is this friendly is this
friendly are you friendly to the person
who was firing behind our dugout and
gratefully it was never the Capitol
Police agent crystal Greiner was
hospitalized with a gunshot wound to her
ankle she graduated in 2006 from
Maryland's Hood College where she played
on the basketball team retired Capitol
police chief Kim Dong she is amazing and
she's a hero she epitomized what being a
hero is all about agent David Bailey was
treated and released for a minor injury
he's from Brazil and graduated from
North Carolina Central University in
2007 his friend Rachel Brooks wasn't
surprised by Bailey's heroics he always
talked about becoming a police officer
and I remember when he first shared that
he was working in Washington DC and that
he was a police officer he was so proud
representative joe barton was there with
his two sons his gratitude to the
officers who saved them was clear
Capitol Hill police
immediately begin
turn fire that sense have been echoed
throughout the capital we are as ever
awed by the tremendous bravery of the
Capitol Police survivors say that if the
Capitol Police officers had not been
there they would have been sitting ducks
and I tell you Gale I know from long
experience here on Capitol Hill that the
Capitol Police Officers often feel like
furniture or wallpaper they feel
unappreciated but today they are being
thanked profusely for being the first
line of defense they really don't have
to hear applause for them yeah across
the board and then their unique fact
that they were there because congressman
Scalise was there otherwise it would
have been theirs and as congressman
Bishop said it was not a fair fight they
had baseball bats and gloves and
handguns against an assault rifle it's
it's extraordinary how different this
story would have turned out had they not
been there thank you very much chip